you can invest in the S P 500 but I
prefer people investing the SME 500s
you're always going to get higher
Returns on investing in your own
education your own skill set compared to
any stock market a buddy of mine has a
daughter she was working at a bowling
alley minimum wage job he told her he's
like you know you can triple your income
if you just get a certification and
become a phlebotomist it takes two days
it's 500 bucks by taking 500 she could
invest in the S P 500 and at 18 years
old maybe there'd be a ton of
compounding but if she invests 500 in
getting the certification and then two
days later she triples her income
probably a better investment in buying
the certification than forever having a
three times higher Baseline for what she
can make my belief is always keep
reinvesting in skills because that
raises your lifetime Baseline of earning
potential